[Music]
this is Satya
everyone my name is Matias and we work
on the v8 team at Google v8 is the
JavaScript engine and the web assembly
engine that's used in Google Chrome and
in other invaders such as node and
electron other chromium based browsers
such as opera and very soon Microsoft
edge also built on top of v8 JavaScript
started out as the scripting language of
the web and to this day it's still a
crucial piece of web technology but
today Java scripts reach extends far
beyond just the web to the entire
surrounding platform so if we take a
step back from v8 and Chrome we can see
that JavaScript allows you to create
engaging web apps across a wide variety
of browsers with node JavaScript can be
used to build command-line tools servers
and other applications with Elektron
JavaScript and other web technologies
can be used able cross-platform desktop
apps react native enables building
cross-platform mobile apps javascript
can even run on low-cost iot devices
nowadays javascript is everywhere so as
a developer learning JavaScript or
improving your javascript skills is an
excellent time investment at Google we
want to enable this enormous JavaScript
ecosystem we do so in multiple ways tc39
is the committee that governs the
evolution of ECMO script which is the
standard behind the JavaScript language
we actively participate in these
standardization efforts together with
other browser vendors and industry
stakeholders bringing back feedback from
us
as implementers and from the developer
community on top of our participation in
the standards process we constantly
improve our own JavaScript engine v8 we
boost its performance reduce its memory
usage and we implement new language
features as they're being standardized
our mission is to lead real-world
performance for modern javascript and
web assembly and to enable developers to
build a faster future web
you might notice webassembly is also
implemented in v8 alongside javascript
our presentation today focuses just on
JavaScript features but it's a separate
web assembly presentation at i/o if
you're interested check out deep tea and
thermos that assembly for web developers
talk later today
now let's discuss what we mean when we
say real-world performance we've stepped
away from synthetic benchmarks where
someone sits down and writes code
specifically for benchmarking purposes
such code often does not reflect
real-world usage and so optimizing for
these scenarios as a javascript engine
has limited impact instead we now focus
on optimizing real websites and
JavaScript applications let's walk
through some example improvements since
chrome 61 we've doubled our raw
JavaScript parsing speed as measured on
real-world websites on top of that we've
managed to move up to 40% of parsing and
compilation work off of the main thread
so that it no longer blocks websites
start up 40% and we're working to
increase this percentage even further
our efforts are not just visible in
Chrome but also node overall promises
got up to 11 times faster between node 7
and node 12 promised at all in
particular got up to 13 times faster to
put that in Chrome version numbers
that's chrome 55 chimera Chrome 74 but
performance is not just about for speed
and runtime performance memory
consumption also plays a big role and
that's why between chrome 70 and Chrome
76 we worked to reduce overall memory
consumption by 20% as measured on
Android go devices running real world
web apps so we've improved startup
performance by boosting JavaScript
parsing speed we've improved runtime
performance by optimizing async and
promises and we've significantly reduced
memory consumption along the way and
those are just some examples of what
we've been working on weight is
something wrong with our slides that
does look funky but I
we talked about this last year in a
regular expression this would be a look
behind I see so I guess it's time to
look back alrighty then exactly one year
ago we were right here at Google i/o
telling you about lots of exciting new
JavaScript features and some of those
features were pretty cutting-edge they
were still being standardized at the
time and so unfortunately for many
features we had to say that they weren't
yet supported in all modern environments
but today one year later feature support
looks a lot better in fact all the
features you see here are now fully
supported across modern browsers and
node you no longer have to polyfill or
transpile these features when targeting
modern environments that means you can
ship smaller JavaScript bundles so your
apps load faster and you get those juicy
performance improvements as well on top
of that some of the other features we
talked about have received updates since
last year let's take a look at what's
changed starting off with class fields
here's a code example that creates an
instance of a class named increasing
counter
note that accessing a value execute some
code in this case it logs a message
before returning the result now ask
yourself how would you implement this in
JavaScript so here's our increasing
counter could be implemented using the
familiar es2015 class syntax Matassa
installs the value getter and an
increment method on the prototype but
more interestingly the class has a
constructor that creates an instance
property underscore count and sets its
default value to zero we currently use
the underscore prefix to denote that
cone should not be used directly by the
consumers of the class but that's just a
convention the privacy is not enforced
by the language anywhere that's what
this class looks like using the old
familiar class syntax the new public
Rossville syntax allows us to simplify
the class definition the count property
is now nicely declared at the top of the
sauce we no longer need a constructor
just to define some fields pretty neat
but the count property is still a public
property in this particular example we
want to prevent direct access to that
property
and that's where private fields come in
so the new private fields syntax is
similar to public fields except you mark
the fields as being private by using the
hash symbol you can think of the hash as
being as part of the field name this is
more than just fancy syntax private
fields are actually private this means
they're not accessible from outside the
class body when you try you get a syntax
error class field syntax is especially
convenient when dealing with subclasses
that introduce additional fields
consider this animal base class for
example to create a cat subclass that
introduces an additional instance
property you'd previously have to call
super to run the constructor of the
animal base class before creating this
property that's a lot of boilerplate
just to indicate that cats don't like
taking baths luckily with the class vl'
syntax it removes the need for the whole
constructor including the awkward super
call all the takes at the class feel is
just that one line chrome supports both
public and private class fields and so
does node and more class features are
coming soon we're working on adding
support for private methods and private
getters and setters another feature we
previewed last year is string match all
which is useful when dealing with
regular expressions it's common to
repeatedly apply the same regular
expression on a string to get all the
matches and to some extent this is
already possible today by using the
string match method in this example we
find all the words that consists of
hexadecimal digits only and then we log
each match however this only
the substrates that match usually you
don't just want the substrings you also
want additional information such as the
index of each sub string or the
capturing groups within each match and
it's already possible to achieve that by
writing your own loop and then keeping
track of the match objects yourself but
it's a little annoying and just not very
convenient the new string match all API
makes this easier than ever before you
can now write a very simple for off loop
to get all the match objects string
match all is especially useful for
regular expressions with capture groups
it gives you the full information for
each individual match including the
capturing groups the general idea is
that you just write a simple for off
loop and string match all takes care of
everything else for you string match all
is already supported in Chrome Firefox
and node for other browsers a polyfill
is available last year we also talked
about the numeric separators proposal
here's a quick recap lodge numeric
controls are difficult for the human eye
to parse quickly especially when there
are lots of repeating digits like in the
first example to improve readability a
new JavaScript feature enables
underscores as separators in numeric
literals so instead of writing these
numbers like this you can now write them
like this grouping the digits per
thousand now it's easier to tell that
the first number is in fact a trillion
and the second number isn't the order of
a billion this small feature helps
improve readability for all kinds of
numeric literals last year this feature
wasn't supported anywhere yet details of
the proposal were still being worked out
but since then the open issues have been
resolved and browsers can now start
implementing it and numeric separators
are already shipping in chrome 75 and
transpilers like babel support them to
speaking of numbers we have some news
about begins as well
here's a quick reminder why bigint is
useful in this example we're multiplying
two numbers now I'm no math genius but
this doesn't look right to me looking at
the least significant digits 9 & 3 we
know that the result of the
multiplication should end in 7 because 9
times 3 is 27
but instead the result ends in a bunch
of zeros that cannot be the correct
result now let's try this again with
Biggins instead and this time we do get
the correct result bacons make it
possible to accurately perform large
integer calculations in JavaScript now
what's new compared to last year is that
big int now has much better API support
within the language for example you can
now format a big int in a locale aware
manner by using the - locale string
method this now works just like it does
for regular numbers in English for
example it's common to use commas to
group the digits per thousand in German
periods are used instead and in French
it's spaces if you plan on supporting
multiple numbers or formatting multiple
numbers or begins using the same locale
it's more efficient to use the intel
number format api that way you can
create a single formatter instance and
then just reuse that as many times as
you need it
this API now supports begins as well and
of course numeric separators work with
bigan literals as well this means that
you can now both use separators to keep
your source code readable and produce
strings with correctly formatted numbers
using locale specific separators all in
vanilla JavaScript I think that's pretty
cool
now last year Biggins had just shipped
in Chrome and they were not available
anywhere else yet but now begins our
shipping in Firefox nightly and in node
and an implementation is also underway
in Safari on top of that there's now a
transpiler and a polyfill story
available for begins it's called a SBI
now let's talk about some new exciting
features that we've been working on
since last year first up is our a flat
and flat map or a flat returns a
flattened version of a given array the
array in this example is two levels deep
it contains an array which in turn
contains another array we can call flat
to flatten the array by one level the
default depth is one but you can pass
any number to recursively flatten up to
that depth to keep flattering
recursively until the result contains no
more nested arrays we can pass infinity
here's another example we have a
duplicate function that takes a value
and returns an array that contains the
value twice if we apply duplicate to
each value in an array we end up with a
nested array you can then call flat to
flatten the array but this since this
pattern is so common in functional
programming there's now a dedicated flat
map method for it flat map is a little
bit more efficient compared to doing a
map followed by a flat separately array
a flat and flat map are already
available in Chrome Firefox Safari and
node another cool new addition to the
built-in JavaScript library is object
from entries you may have used to object
entries API before that one has been
around for a while for each key value
pair in an object it gives you an array
where the first element is the key and
the second element is the value and this
is especially useful in combination with
for off because you can then very
elegantly iterate over all the key value
pairs in an object now unfortunately
there's no easy way to go from the
entries result back to an equivalent
object until now the new object from
entries API performs the inverse of
object entries
this makes it really easy to reconstruct
an object based on its entries now why
is this useful
well one common use case is transforming
objects you can now do this by iterating
over the objects entries and then using
array methods that you are probably
already familiar with in this example
we're filtering the object to only get
keys of length 1 that is we only want
the keys x and y but not the key ABC we
then map over the remaining entries and
return an updated key value pair for
each in this example we double the value
by multiplying it by 2 and the end
result is a new object containing only
the properties x and y with the new
values javascript also supports maps
which are often a more suitable data
structure than regular objects so in
code that you have full control over you
might already be using maps instead of
objects however as a developer you don't
always get to choose the representation
sometimes the data that you're operating
on comes from an external API or from
some library function that gives you an
object instead of a map an object
entries made it easy to convert objects
into maps but the inverse is equally
useful even if your code is using Maps
you might need to serialize your data at
some points for example to turn it into
JSON to send an API request or maybe you
need to pass the data to another library
that expects an object instead of a map
in these cases you need to create an
object based on the map data an object
from entries makes this trivial with
both object entries and object from
entries in the language you can now
really easily convert between maps and
objects both ways object from entries is
already shipping in Chrome Firefox
Safari and in node for older browser
versions a polyfill is available another
new feature seems like a small one but
it's a big improvement so here's the
problem libraries and polyfills
sometimes need access to the
global this value the right universal
JavaScript that works everywhere
regardless of whether you're in a
browser in node or in a JavaScript
engine shell directly you need code like
this to access the global disk in
browsers you can use window except in
web workers or service workers window is
not available so you have to check for
self as well in node you can use global
instead but in standalone JavaScript
shells none of these work so you can try
falling back to whatever this object is
currently available but outside of
browsers that still won't work within
modules since they don't run in the
global scope or in strict mode functions
since there this is undefined also
bundler is often wrapped source code in
which case this might refer to something
else entirely you cannot rely on this
code being run in the global scope in
all cases so even though we're trying
really hard for this code snippet it
still doesn't support standalone
JavaScript engine shells doesn't support
modules in all environments it doesn't
support strict mode functions in all
environments and it might even break in
more scenarios when you start bundling
it getting the global this sounds like
it would be simple but it's actually
painful to do so in practice and that's
why we have a new global this feature
that gives you easy access to the global
dis regardless of the environment global
this is already supported in Chrome
Firefox Safari and node note that most
modern code will need access to the
global this with JavaScript modules you
can decoratively import and export
functionality without messing with
global state global this is still useful
for polyfills and other libraries that
need global access
stable sort is another one of those
changes that sounds like a small
improvement but it actually has a big
impact let's say you have an array of
dogs and each dog has a name and the
rating if this sounds like a weird
example you should know that there is a
Twitter account that specializes in
exactly that
don't ask anyway the array is pre sorted
alphabetically by name but what if you
want to sort this array by rating so
that the highest rated dogs show up
first you would use array sort for this
and you would pass in a custom callback
that compares the ratings and this is
the result that you would probably
expect the dogs are now sorted by rating
but within each rating they're still
sorted alphabetically by name they
retain their relative original order for
example Shoko and ghost have the same
rating of 14 but choko appears before
ghost in the sort result because that's
the order they had in the original array
as well to get this result however you
cannot just use any sorting algorithm it
has to be a so-called stable sort and
for a long time the JavaScript spec
didn't require sort stability for array
sort instead it left it up to the
implementation and because this behavior
wasn't specified you could also get this
sort result where ghost now suddenly
appears before Shoko
in other words JavaScript developers
could not rely on sort stability and in
practice it was even more confusing than
that because some JavaScript engines
would use a stable sort for short arrays
but an unstable sort for larger arrays
that was really confusing because
developers would test their code they
would see a stable result but then
suddenly get a completely unstable
result when the array was slightly
bigger but there's some good news we
proposed the spec change that makes a
race horse stable and it was accepted
and all major JavaScript engines now
implement a stable array sorts it's just
one last thing for you as a JavaScript
developer to worry about v8 also
implements several int'l api's that
provide key locale specific function
such as date formatting number
formatting plural form selection and
collation in JavaScript
these api's allow you to localize your
websites without having to ship hundreds
of kilobytes of locale data to the user
let's look at some of the new features
we've added recently modern web
applications of a new stressor is like
yesterday 42 seconds ago or in three
quarters instead of full dates or
timestamps the inter-rater time format
API can generate these phrases for you
for each language you support this code
example creates a relative time for
matter for the English language we set
the numeric option to auto to tell the
formatter it can use phrases like
yesterday instead of one day ago the
formatter recognizes several time units
such as seconds minutes hours days
months quarters and weeks be positon
number and a unit and it returns a
string that represents the relative time
and this doesn't just work for English
but for other languages like Tamil as
well
previously developers had no choice but
to implement such api's themselves one
problem with implementing a localized
later time for matter is that you need a
list of customary words or phrases such
as yesterday or last quarter for each
languages support the Unicode cldr
provides this data but you use it in
JavaScript it has to be shipped
alongside other library code this
unfortunately increases the bundle size
for such libraries which negatively
impacts load time parse compile time and
memory consumption with the new int
already time format API the browser
ships the data so you get the
functionality without paying the cost
the relative time from an API is
available in Chrome Firefox and node
modern web applications often use lists
consisting of dynamic data and they
require locale specific formatting of
such lists for example a photo viewer
app might display a message like this
photo includes person a B and C the
Intel list format API can help you
format such strings for any given
language using the locale specific list
conventions a text-based game might have
a different kind of list it could say
something like Seuss your favorite hero
X Y or Z the list format API supports
that too using the disjunction type now
because each language has different list
formatting conventions and words
implementing a localized list formatter
in JavaScript is non-trivial not only
does this require a list of all the
words such as ant or or for each
language you want to support in addition
you need to encode the exact formatting
conventions for all those languages the
int'l list format api takes care of all
of that for you the list format proposal
is available in chrome and node for
other browsers a polyfill is available
it's common for websites to display data
intervals or date ranges to show the
span of an event such as a hotel
reservation the billing period of a
service or I don't know a big tech
developer festival in one view the
format range method for it's a
convenient way of formatting ranges in a
local specific manner in the above
example we create two dates and from the
date using date-time format day time
format is an existing API that has been
shipping in all browsers fro ila so one
way to print the date range is to use
the regular locale and our string
formatting you format the start date you
format the end date and piece them
together into a string here the second
dates month and your calendar feel
are redundant only they provides new
information so instead with the new
format range method we can display only
the relevant fields and none of the
repeating ones the format range method
is available behind a flag in Chrome and
we plan to ship it very soona in the
previous examples you may have noticed a
local ID that we passed to the various
intelligence truckers such as en for
English in Toluca offers a powerful
mechanism to deal with such locales it
enables easily extracting locale
specific references such as not only the
language but also the calendar the
numbering system the hour cycle the
region and so on the into locale
proposal is now available in chrome and
note you can use a polyfill for all the
browsers if you've used promises before
you might already be familiar with a
lovely async/await syntax instead of
chaining promise callbacks using then
you can nicely await the result of a
promise this syntax has been around for
a while now
however a wait can only occur within an
async function but there are use cases
for one thing to use a wait at the top
level but currently this isn't possible
one workaround is taking all your top
level code wrapping it up in an async
function that you then call another
approach is to wrap your top level code
in an immediately invoked async function
expression but a new proposal enables
the use of await at the top level
removing the need for these workarounds
now the chrome dev tools console already
wraps your input in an async function
behind the scenes if the input contains
a weight so it looks like top level
weight already works in the console but
that's not because we implement a
proposal we don't the exact details of
the top level weight proposal are still
being worked out and as such it's still
too early to implement it it's not
currently supported everywhere
so now that we're on the subject of
promises and async code let's talk about
promise api's currently there are two
promise combinators in javascript the
static method all andreas promise not
all lets you know when either all input
promises have fulfilled or when one of
them rejects promise dot race let's you
know as soon as one of the input settles
which means either fulfills or rejects
these are independently useful and have
different use cases so imagine if the
user clicks a button and you want to
load some style sheets so you can render
a completely new UI this program kicks
off an HTTP request for each style sheet
in parallel then you only want to start
running the new UI after all the
requests succeed but if something goes
wrong you want to instead display an
error message as soon as possible
without waiting for any other work to
finish in such a case you could use
promised at all you want to know when
all promises are fulfilled or as soon as
one of them rejects promise that race is
useful if you want to run multiple
promises and aid or do something with
the first successful result that comes
in in case one of the promise fulfills
or do something as soon as one of the
promise rejects that is if one of the
promise rejects you want to preserve
that rejection and treat that error case
separately here we do exactly that we
kick off a computationally expensive
task that might take a long time where
we race it against a promise that
rejects after two seconds depending on
the first promised to fulfill or reject
we either render the computer result or
the error message in two separate code
parts there was a top-level await in
that example by the way so those are the
existing promise Combinator's
and race to new proposals are currently
making their way to the standardization
process promised all settled and
promised any with these additions there
will be a total of four promised
Combinator's in JavaScript each enabling
different use cases promise all settled
gives you a signal when all of the input
promises are settled and that means
they're either fulfilled or rejected
this is useful in those cases where you
don't really care about the state of the
promise you just want to know when the
work is done regardless of whether it
was successful for example you can kick
off a series of independent API calls
and then use promised all settled to
make sure that they're all completed
before doing something else like
removing a loading spinner promise any
gives you a signal as soon as one of the
promises fulfills this is similar to
promise race except any doesn't reject
early when one of the promises rejects
this code example checks which end point
responds the fastest and then logs it
only if all of the requests fail do we
end up in the catch block where we can
then handle the errors promise that any
is still in the early stages of being
standardized and it's not supported
anywhere yet but promise all settled on
the other hand is already available in
chrome 76 and in Firefox nightly for
other browsers a polyfill is available
next up or weak references generally
references to objects are strongly held
in JavaScript meaning that as long as
you have a reference to an object that
object won't be garbage collected
currency weak Maps and weak sets or the
only way to weakly reference an object
adding an object to a weak map or a weak
set doesn't prevent it from being
garbage-collected weak references are
more advanced API that provide a window
into the lifetime of an object so here
we have a get image function that takes
a name and perform some expensive
operation to generate another object
like a binary blob of
match data to improve performance we
store the image in a cache now we don't
have to perform the expensive operation
again for the same name but there's a
problem
maps hold on to the keys and values
strongly so the image names and data can
never be garbage collected
so this steadily increases memory and
costs a memory leak note that using a
weak map would not help you as weak maps
don't support strings as keys a new
proposal makes it possible to solve the
memory leak by creating a weak reference
to the image and storing that in the
cache instead of the image itself so
when the garbage collector realizes that
it's running out of memory it can clean
up some of the images but there's still
a problem here the map still holds on to
the name strings forever because those
are the keys in the cache ideally those
strings would be removed as well the
week crafts proposal has a solution for
that as well with the new finalization
group API we can register a callback to
run when the garbage collector zaps a
registered object so here we register a
callback to remove the keys from the
cache when the image objects are garbage
collected so our final implementation
looks like this given an image name we
look up its corresponding weak reference
in the cache if the weak reference still
points to something we can return the
cached image data if there's no cache
entry yet or if the cached data has
already been garbage collected we
compute the image data create a new weak
reference to it store the image name and
weak reference in the cash register a
finalizer that removes the image name
from the cache once the image data is
garbage collected and returned the image
the we craps proposal is still going
through the standardization process we
have an experimental in
plantation in immediate behind a flag
already but we won't ship it until the
proposal is finished now we've talked
about lots of amazing JavaScript
features today with for wrying degrees
of supports I'm very excited to see how
much the JavaScript landscape has
evolved over the past year and we look
forward to increased support and
adoption of these new features across
the entire ecosystem and who knows maybe
next year we'll be back here at Google
i/o announcing that all these
cutting-edge features are now supported
everywhere wouldn't that be nice
fingers crossed if you have any feedback
at all on this session or have any
questions about modern JavaScript then
don't hesitate to let us know on Twitter
thanks for listening and enjoy the rest
of i/o
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]